sam raimi dr. strange - no smarter
before uh uh then what
quit me the hell's kwibi sam raimi
brings us a horror anthology for kwibi
so we're gonna do a reaction is the
first trailer I'm watching for anything
from kwibi we will share our thoughts on
the quay she's such a funny word
streaming platform afterwards and of
course thoughts on the trailer
fun fact kwibi actually stands for quick
bites because these are all phone
conchis to come yes
oh that's cool so it's gonna be like an
anthology story in one state each yeah
that's Nate every story is a different
state I guess yeah
[Music]
just like a [ __ ] TV joint that's such a
Sam Raimi's I forgot I mention the title
of it that's why what it was like every
Stella oh okay so for you guys you don't
know what kwibi is apparently it's a new
streaming platform that's only for
mobile devices they'll have shows where
the episodes are only like 5 to 10
minutes long I like the concept of that
that actually sounds pretty cool and
especially considering that a lot of
people you watch they're streaming
platforms at YouTube included from their
phone so I'm like okay that's the smart
thing to tend to the other thing that
struck me while I was cutting this video
is that they'll probably be able to make
really good use of whatever budget they
have given that the episodes are only 5
to 10 minutes that's literally like
double the value for the money you could
get as opposed to like a 22-minute show
so that's you know especially for a
horror show
pretty exciting as well I guess the one
bummer of a fact that kind of stems from
this is when I see a trailer like this
I'm like this would be awesome to watch
on my television actually yeah and I
wonder if they'll graduate to that that
being said though when I see a horror
show or something like this I also
imagine that if you're watching the
right move some good headphones
especially with Sam Raimi produced
content or directed I'm sure you may be
helmed a few of these episodes it can
make it that much more scary and
immersive hey I love the idea of
adapting or revamping urban legends from
each state solid idea to get a great 50
episodes in there and then of course the
effects I love it there's a lot of great
looking practical there's some throwback
vibes obvious
because you're exploring these urban
legends that's just a great I think
that's just a great concept it's like a
horror story in each state a that's a
really awesome thing to explore because
every state or most it usually has
multiple stories and then you know if
this is a success they can go to other
countries or whatever I love this idea
this feels like a great mix of Sam Raimi
mixed with some modern-day [ __ ] TV
aesthetic and the idea of kwibi I think
is a cool idea for maybe be cool to
pitch some ideas for them to the road
yeah you never know I mean this is an
interesting thing to see partly because
I think now with the world the way it is
we're gonna do a lot of interesting
experimenting with mobile and web-based
content that's fully intended for that
and just knowing that they are going
into this with that idea that you know
you're probably gonna be watching on
your phone I think for a horror show
especially there are a lot of good
opportunity like you can be watching in
your bed at night and as much as yeah I
would want to see some of this big
that's also a perfect place to get
scared
so yeah just the look of the production
values and the different settings and
IRA's and stuff that they're going for
looks really fun and having worked for
horror websites in the past every state
yeah has a bunch of urban legends those
stories you see them recycled over and
over again in write-ups online but yet
actually start visualizing them seems
like a really great idea because even if
it needs to find its footing way to mix
it up every single time so yeah I'm
really excited for what this is and I
hope it takes off yeah alright guys well
are you gonna get the quick you can get
like the first 90 days for free is that
what the trailer said soon or am I
remembering some text I read yeah 90
days free April 6th I think oh my god
it's coming up are you gonna get the
kwibi
app are you excited for this show leave
your thoughts down below subscribe to
the reel rejects click that notification
mill and what if it could react many of
these check us on patreon where we do TV
show reactions by the way see you guys